[Music]
okay everybody so this is my
spoiler-free review of eternals so i
just want to open my review saying that
i was not a big fan of the best picture
winner in nomad land which was directed
and written by chloe zhao which is the
case here but she also has a couple
writers with her this time around
and
that for me was something that lowered
my expectations dramatically because my
problem with no mad land was i was never
engaged i thought it was missing any
kind of story and i was worried with the
eternals trailers that this looked kind
of boring that we might get that case
because we're seeing who's behind it so
i i really brought my expectations down
and
i was totally stunned
how much i was the complete opposite of
nomad land and was totally engaged this
whole movie and absolutely was blown
away by what chloe did here so i already
knew from nomad land how good she is
visually storytelling but
here i mean what she does with this
marvel
entity is incredible i mean it is a
spectacle to watch but that was expected
but wasn't expected to me again was an
engaging story to come along with it and
i was really impressed by her writing
here i mean what was so great about
eternals to me is that
a key to great storytelling a lot of
people think it's always you know
focusing on characters but it's really
great relationships and stories that
make it really feel like payoff and this
story focused on making really good
relationships between many characters
here and what's so hard to pull off with
that is everyone's got to have a certain
amount of weight that's why i think the
runtimes justified at almost 2 hours and
47 minutes it felt like it flew by for
me but i think it was perfectly planned
out that everyone got enough screen time
that you cared about all of them
but the more important thing was that
each relationship had weight to it
between these characters everyone served
a purpose and got their time and it
really kind of wraps around really well
towards the end of the film people will
say oh it's it's the same old same old
mcu but i completely disagree i think
this is the most refreshing mcu we've
gotten in years
i usually leave marvel movies thinking
like okay it was always pretty good like
they're always a safe
call with marvel they have a just a
quality standard but i haven't been
blown away a while by their films last
time i actually left blown away was
infinity war so this was the first time
i left again blown away which shocked me
i felt like it was something new i think
that
with eternals
you see that it's not relying on the
other marvel films to keep its story
going it's not obsessed with easter eggs
and references it's its own entity and i
think that's what we really needed here
so we don't feel kind of tired with all
this stuff in the mcu especially because
we have so many shows coming on disney
plus with marvel and a lot of them do
heavily rely which is great on that
canon connecting stories but this was
set out to just make a great movie on
its own right and worry about that stuff
for post-credits scenes which by the way
there's two post-credits scenes and
thank you variety reporter for spoiling
the mid-credits scene which i'm
obviously not going to say but it's a
huge blur that got out that i was ruined
by but what was pleasantly surprising is
there's an even better post credit scene
after the mid-credits scene that wasn't
leaked so get ready for that it was
absolutely bonkers that really got me
excited too so some of the best
post-credits scenes we've seen in mcu
yet but back to this the main story here
i'm gonna say too that
i loved every actor here and
gemma chan who is the lead of this film
clearly proves she is a great leading
lady here i mean the range of emotions
she's able to display on her face but
also
how she gets you invested in her
character with not too much dialogue
either which is
really a tribute to her acting but also
you know there's great casting here that
comes with that so because you have
clearly kumail nanjiani who's cast it
here as obviously going to be comedy
relief but he was great you know i
thought he was perfect for this part and
i thought the humor in this film
surprisingly made me laugh really hard
it is a very funny movie to me i thought
this would be super serious it really is
and isn't and it's not that typical you
know one-liners you see in marvel after
like during the middle of an action
scene that breaks it up i like that
chloe chow
decided to sparingly use the humor but
in the right moments and let them kind
of be humorous scenes on their own
without interrupting certain important
serious moments which i appreciated
people are already saying that this
one's going to be very divisive but
i'll tell you this and i don't care if i
sound you know very arrogant saying this
but this one is for the smarties this
marvel film because
if you're not with what's going on you
might get bored but this one to me made
me think the whole time and made me feel
emotional and really was challenging my
brain in a good way but i think that's
also what made me engaged the whole time
and made me feel like this was a fresh
mcu feature where sometimes i feel like
in other marvel films you know they're
not really pulling your brain and
challenge you that much where this is
kind of taking a next step which i
appreciated i really suggest seeing this
in imax i mean there's moments with the
celestials where you're like whoa like
it is big but it's not like overbearing
cgi and obsessed with cgi this film no
and i think what's great is we know
eternals are powerful but the foes they
put in this film are worthy and
that makes it always feel like there's a
chance someone could go and die and
there's also
huge stakes but also really big twist in
the middle i thought that was really
good that you won't really see coming i
think angelina jolie's character was my
favorite in fina she's got a very
interesting tick about her character
which you'll see which i won't spoil but
again i was not disappointed with that
and of course lauren ridloff here who is
just awesome in everything she does i
love during walking dead but she has
this likability that i don't know many
actresses have in the industry right now
she just has that aura about her and
she's just great to root for and that
happens in this film and she gets a nice
moment to shine as well and i'm always
worried you know when they have a kid
character as a lead like that it can get
cheesy or you start rolling your eyes
with it but no the girl here was amazing
and i love that they kind of
eventually reveal what her character is
inspired by in the film itself and it's
actually fascinating and i like what
they did with it so
that's really interesting too so you
also get surprises with the characters
that you kind of get adjusted to by the
middle of the film and then there's some
twists for each of them that you're like
okay i didn't expect that now i'm giving
all this praise but again
there was some issues i had i think
clearly the third act is its weakest it
gets a little messy and that is where it
feels a little drawn out but i do
appreciate in the battle sequence in the
third act it's not your usual everybody
versus one big cgi monster and we just
watch it happen it gets kind of boring
there's some interesting staging here
and multiple separate fights going on
which i think is more interesting and
another weird thing i didn't like and
this isn't spoiling at all but you'll
see one of the main eternals characters
is just completely missing in the third
act it's bizarre and there's actually no
real explanation for
why they went that route or you're not
you don't really get a payoff of like
okay that's why they did that at the end
it just never comes so that's really
interesting once you see the film i i'm
gonna be interested what you guys think
on that and honestly
i'm a huge fan of composer i'm gonna
butcher his name rahman dawadi who
did westworld he's done so many good
scores game of thrones
and i did not think the score was great
here and it could have been amazing
maybe marvel was limiting what he could
do here but he felt almost like muted in
very background like i never felt
a vibe of what is the sound to the
eternals what is that feeling you get
from music it just never even crossed my
mind his score which you know i don't
know who to blame for that but it was
definitely
forgettable i don't have one feeling of
music in my head that i left with or
excited to download on spotify let's say
so that was disappointing but i'm i'm
serious like
i thought this movie was magical and
if you know my reviews i'm very hard on
tons of movies i try to be as unbiased
as possible i'm not a fanboy here i'm
not a marvel fanboy just gonna praise
everything or oh i got to see it early
so i'm gonna say good things no this
movie for me
was a 9.3 the best marvel film i've seen
since infinity war and i was so so about
endgame but this to me is right up there
infinity war for me um
like i said i always leave marvel movies
thinking they're solid but not blown
away this one
blew me away um and i'll go to the bank
i'll die on that hill here like you go
see that movie if you have some sort of
a brain on you and you appreciate
relationships in films and feelings that
you can also relate to in different
circumstances in life because there's so
many different characters here but they
all get enough weight you're gonna feel
rewarded and you just feel like you come
out
complete from this movie if that makes
any sense i feel like i grew as a person
watching this i know doesn't sound like
makes sense but see this movie you'll
know what i'm talking about i guarantee
you're going to like it
let me know in the comments below if
you've seen it already if you plan on
seeing it your thoughts i read every
comment try to respond as many as i can
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews of any
movies or tv shows that i also do and i
also do celebrity interviews and please
follow me at steve barley show on
twitter instagram and tick tock for more
of me and i'll see you next time